here's a fun geometry problem we have a
circle we have a couple of tangent line
segments with length equal to one and we
have a couple of golden triangles with
area equal to one the question is to
solve for the radius of the circle to
get started suppose the other leg has
length equal to X then since its area is
equal to one we have x times one over
two is equal to one which means X is
equal to two
from here we can solve for the
hypotenuse of the triangle it'll be the
square root of one squared plus two
squared which is equal to the square
root of five now let R be the radius of
the circle we can now focus on this
right triangle and we must have that r
squared plus the square of one plus
square root of 5 is equal to the square
of R plus two we can expand each
binomial and then cancel out the r
squared terms to get that 4r is equal to
two plus two root 5. this means R is
equal to one plus root 5 all over two
which is equal to the golden ratio which
is approximately 1.618